was ist das ganz ehrlich einfach ich
mache eine challenge anstößigen
deathmatch auch noch auf den hacker als
wäre es schon schwer genug sex kids und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
ich habe heute eine neue challenge für
euch die werden wie in berlin und zwar
bevor ich überhaupt los laufe die
challenge lautet inventar verboten das
heißt sobald ich jetzt mal inventar
geklärt habe also hier oben die rüstung
werde ich einmal komplett weg werfen
darf ich die taste eh nicht mal drücken
main event nicht mehr öffnen so das
heißt ich spiele diese runde
ausschließlich mit meiner wortwahl
das ist schwierig weil wenn es zum
beispiel umrüstung geht macht mir dass
das leben ziemlich schwer denn brüstung
die ich einmal angezogen habe kann ich
nicht wieder ausziehen denn ich kann ja
nicht öffnen und die rüstung aussehen
das heißt muss mir genau überlegen
welche rüstung ich anziehe
weil zum beispiel viele zugewinn zeit
gemerkt weil zum beispiel eine gold
spade vielleicht eine schlechte wahl
sein könnte weil ich dann eventuell
später anreisen chat bekomme und dann
kann ich diese gold spade die ich habe
nicht ausziehen und nicht wechseln
obwohl ich eigentlich eine bessere jobs
und waren völlig darunter ok vielleicht
bin ich einfach zu alt trickst mit
erklären ein von den ja ok guck mal hier
gold ist so ok guten shane helm fährt
pfeiler nämlich auch mit die fehler
meine ich aber auch nicht anders war
okay okay gut jetzt darf ich aber jetzt
nicht mal einmal in ordnung aber jetzt
ist schluss mit
ich sage ich zieh mal den chain hellmann
so angezogen den kann ich jetzt nicht
mehr ausziehen
das gute ist übrigens für den fall dass
ich finde schon sollte alte wohl nachts
einfach gerade nicht aussieht weil einer
so übertrieben absurd da vorne oder
gleich zwei kriege ich ja die degut sind
die die abos werden automatisch
angezogen zeit dafür muss man nicht mehr
das inventar öffnen muss ein bisschen
gas geben hier
das nehme ich mit das nehme ich mit und
ich drücke nicht ich war heute da wieder
drücken auf die holz einfach so weg zack
zack müssens ein bisschen bei allen hier
bei den letzten runden ist mir
aufgefallen es gibt so richtig viele
extrem gute jump league spieler die
einen einfach so derbe abzocken wenn man
nicht wirklich gas gibt so hier
die angel dem ich noch mit aber gucken
hier leute ich habe noch einen slot frei
in der ort war
das heißt wenn gleich was passiert muss
ich wenn ich gleich wieder equipment
kriege oder items muss ich
wahrscheinlich irgendwas wegwerfen und
zwar was wird es sein event schauen was
ist es gibt es mal hier
okay die all blacks dafür werfe ich das
ding weg was haben wir noch kräftig mit
ich werfe mal die golden bu zweck jedoch
die sticks mit ok gut was habe ich jetzt
gemacht
ich glaub ich hab die acht ich habe
unglaublich aufgesammelt obwohl die haut
war voll ist ich guck mal kurz ich drück
kurzum das wieder weg zu werfen
genau die golden bu zwar und und den
alben helm den goldhelm rechnet auch bei
welchen change schon ab also die change
eigentlich echt witzig des konzerns die
challenge habt ihr gesehen wie erotisch
ich jetzt ausgesprochen habe neues album
ok alles rein apfelbeck fehlern weg in
ein apfel ich möchte sagt so machen was
okay ich zieh dir allem gut an sehr gut
so das ist schon mal das beste was
eigentlich passieren kann aus einer
kiste
das beste aus einer kiste passieren kann
das einzige was noch passieren kann ist
dass wir ohne finnischen um das dann
ende eben am ende die coop holen problem
ist nur dass die sachen die ganze zeit
hier auf die spur werfe auf dem parcours
ich sollte eigentlich lieber raus werfen
merke ich mir fürs nächste mal okay
bauleiter kleiner lag aber ich bin drauf
nice trotz weggeschafft sehr geil ich
bin übrigens bottrop ich bin der der
kühne bob sport heißt kühen nicht
verwechseln bolt das heißt karl ok
checken was haben wir nehmen
jacobs das verfahren so ihr fragt euch
vielleicht warum jetzt die größte lohn
aufbewahre sache ist ich weiß nicht wann
die anderen finnischen das heißt ich
halte mir lieber ein bisschen mehr
equipment hier so als ob man hier was
haben wir alles klar
und so die sich beide an
dann habe ich ihr platz für den
eisenbahnen für den anwendbaren genau
und zack zack zack
so jetzt kommt wieder dieser schwierige
partie ich habe eigentlich eine
strategie wie ich das mache nein also
meine strategie ist eigentlich dass ich
da ich zeig euch gleich wenn ich oben
bin wenn ich noch mal hoch komme finde
ich schon die anderen modi sind hier
schon durch zumindest einer ist ja schon
durch der homo lp ist schon durch mit
diesem parcours
rose apps schon durch das heißt sie muss
gas geben dass der nicht finished oder
hängt er da oben auch gerade scheint zu
hängen
so here zack zack zack gut und jetzt ok
also ich nicht so raus und dann einfach
ohne sprinten und ohne es liegen also
einfach ganz normal springen und damit
den richtungstasten versuchen sich darum
zu manövrieren das klappt eigentlich
relativ oft nur jetzt halt gerade
vorführung des effekt ins heim ist dann
funktioniert es nicht nur ums leben
so also ganz raus ist ja ok aber das war
schon besser das war besser aber glaubt
mir das klappt auf jeden fall so ist
zumindest meine beste methode wie man
das lösen kann
hier könnte mal ausprobieren ob das bei
euch auch funktioniert ich glaube ich
eine gute idee ein gutes idee die
dummheit nimmt überhand
so aber ich hab schon ich habe eine
vorrüstung nicht voll andere gute und es
regel befolgt mit dem schein helm
perfekt sei ich muss auch keine
liegestützen machen so klappt es bei mir
so mache ich das und jetzt nein dann bin
ich zu unkonzentriert dann schaffe ich
das ding einmal und dann bin ich bei dem
letzten sprung der eigentlich noch was
ein bisschen schwierig ist dann
unkonzentriert
das ist bitter das ist bitter aber ich
habe gutes equipment
ich habe eigentlich gutes equipment um
hier runterzufallen in dieser stelle
dafür bin ich perfekt wippt mit meiner
eigenen und konzentriert hat immer
wieder sah ich möchte eigentlich auch
ganz gerne diesen parcours immer
schaffen
ob ich hab's gefühl einer von den zwei
schweren meter vor mir finish jetzt
leichter gucken ob es hier jetzt hier
schaffe raus da
nein da bin ich nicht konsequent genug
rausgegangen ok ich muss auf jeden fall
erstmal raus also seitlich weg da und
darf dann erst über steuern
sonst funktioniert es nicht also ich
hoffe ihr versteht was ich meine jetzt
gerade raus und drüber steuern also dass
man erst mal ein stück nach links raus
springt und dann ist mein ernst muss ich
jetzt sagen oder mercedes college okay
ich bleib mir einfach hängen jetzt
schauen wir mal wie sich das im
deathmatch spielen lässt wir kriegen
noch ein kompost rein da ist das heißt
wir haben ein kompass und davon ist
jetzt unser gegner wie bei uns er sieht
es nicht so ausgesehen
okay er was ist das alter spielt ja wir
haben beide teams bekommen
aber wie kommt dieser homepage liefert
der gefressen
also ist es irgendwie ein neues team auf
das unmögliche noch beck zu vermeiden
dass man im sprungs nicht abholen wie
kam das bisschen komisch vor
ehrlich gesagt spielt man ja der hat
doch noch weg er hat nur noch weg alles
klar
natürlich nur noch weg gott nein nein
nein nein nein
die heutige junge ok bitte reporten
reporter diesen vfl da drecks kind ohne
witz einfach mal mit nur noch weg in die
dumping kunde rein
ich will einfach wieder aufleben ich hab
schon schwer genug kommt ein fall unter
hecken kannst du eh nix alter er guckt
euch das an hat einfach so will ich nur
noch weg und ich habe ihn nicht mehr
erwischt wahrscheinlich hätte noch übrig
hexen oder so also what the [ __ ] egal
egal
dann probieren jetzt einfach mit diesem
hacker bisschen zu spielen möchte
fordern die kiste gehen ja sehr schön
mal kurz weg du bist nämlich auch noch
auf die andere kann ich eigentlich
verzichten
mal gucken was hier drin ist ein fall
was nehme ich mir was nämlich mit
hindus tnt mit dem ist ihm lieber ist in
feierlich gesagt war dann ein trainer
ist nicht ob nicht kann also jetzt jetzt
nur noch ich und der hacker alter diese
kleine miss it und ich sind jetzt die
letzten die hier bleiben so okay leute
ich mache einfach was ist das ganz
ehrlich einfach ich mache eine challenge
anstößigen deathmatch auch noch auf den
hacker als wäre es schon nicht schwer
genug man als wäre es ja okay okay aber
er ist nicht so gut mit pfeil und bogen
als wir sein müssen wir sehen was ich an
alina eckey noch berg also der klare
beweis er spielt mit noch besser was
machen wir jetzt noch kommt ist ein
bisschen schwierig zu spielen weil man
die nicht wegschlagen kann
ja ich habe gewonnen ich habe gefühlt
direkt kicker hacker reporter.de
wunderbar alter ich habe tatsächlich den
hacker noch gechillt und ich sowie der
seinen kopf bewegt hatte denn nicht nur
noch berg sondern vielleicht auch noch
irgendwie komforts philosophie so den
kampf eingang aber leute hält was für
eine challenge wir haben die challenge
gemeistert und wir haben noch ein hacker
im deathmatch umgelegt und haben noch
gewonnen perfekt ich bin zufrieden leute
weil ich das video auch gefallen hat
dann macht denn hier